(light rock music)
- Well now it's time for
tonight's Hashtag Wars.
(audience cheering)
- [Chris] Brandon.
(Brandon wailing)
- Sweet Christ of mine!
(audience laughing)
- Points.
(dinging)
Alex.
- Santa Baby Batter.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(Chris laughing)
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Points, Paul Tompkins.
- The Little One-Armed Drummer Boy.
- Yes, points.
(audience appluading)
(dinging)
Brandon Johnson.
- Hannukah!
Hannukah!
(Brandon grunting)
- Yes, points, points for Panama.
(audience applauding)
Paul.
- Do you hear what I hear, nothing right?
So put more vocals in the (bleep) monitor!
(audience laughing)
- Points, points.
(dinging)
Brandon Johnson.
- Come on, feel the toys!
- Perfect, points.
(audience applauding)
(dinging)
Paul Tompkins.
- Honestly?
(Paul laughing)
Mother (bleep).
(Chris laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Chris] Sorry it's like-
- I'm pressing, I'm pressing!
Go, go!
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- Yes, Almadrigal.
- Hitchhiker's Guide To Being
Buried An a Shallow Grave
Outside Needles, California.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Points, Jim Jeffries.
- Mein Kampf II: And Here's
What I Think About Asians.
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
- Points.
(dinging)
Rhysie.
- Jekyll and Hyde II:
Let's Talk About Bipolar.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, points.
(dinging)
Rhysie.
- Oliver Twist Ending.
(audience laughing)
- Oh, whoa!
Points!
(dinging)
- Al.
- Seven Excuses of Highly
Successful Failures.
(audience laughing)
- Yes points.
(dinging)
Jim.
- The Diary of Anne
Frank II: Still Hiding.
(audience laughing)
- Points, points.
(dinging)
- A Gland Before Time.
- [Chris] Points.
(audience applauding)
(dinging)
Brooks.
- Wild Wild Tits.
- Yeah, points.
(audience applauding)
(dinging)
Mameri.
- Double Jeapor-Ds.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience cheering)
(dinging)
Judah.
- How Stella Got Her Tits Back.
- [Chris] Yeah, points.
(audience cheering)
(dinging)
Mamerie.
- New Jack Titty.
- [Chris] Yes, of course,
points.
(dinging)
(audience cheering)
Judah.
- Motor boat trip.
- [Chris] Points.
(audience applauding)
(dinging)
Brooks.
- It's a Beautiful Life
Because of My Wife's Tits.
- Points.
I'll tell you, sometimes I wish these tits
were never born, Clarence.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Mamerie.
- Nip-Lash, its a new release.
(audience laughing)
- Yes, points, Judah.
- The Curious Case of Benjamin Butt Tits.
(Chris laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Chris] Kurt.
- The LOLs-icaust.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience groaning)
- It's a historical event!
- Points.
(dinging)
Doug.
- We have nothing to
fear but fear it-selfie.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Kurt.
- Twitter War of 1812.
- Points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Doug.
- The Boston totes party.
- Points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Megan.
- Oh, really, oh.
(Doug laughing)
- [Chris] Well, yeah you were hitting it.
- I don't know I was but-
- You should know when you're
touching your own button.
- I don't know-
(audience laughing)
- Alright, a hundred points.
(audience cheering)